Determina el número de soluciones de la ecuación cuadrática,
"x" cuadrada más "14x" más 49 igual a 0.
Y hay un montón de formas en el que podríamos
resolver esto, por ejemplo, podríamos factorizarlo
y simplemente descubrir los valores de "x"
que las satisfagan y después solo contarlos.
Ese sería nuestro número de soluciones,
otra forma, sería simplemente aplicar la
fórmula cuadrática, pero lo que quiero hacer
en este momento es explorar la fórmula cuadrática
y pensar en cómo podemos determinar el número
de soluciones sin siquiera tal vez necesariamente
hallarlas de una forma explicita.
Bueno, la fórmula cuadrática nos dice que
si tenemos una ecuación de la forma "ax"
cuadrada más "bx" más "c" igual a 0, entonces
la soluciones van a ser de la forma...
o las soluciones si existen, son de la forma
"x" es igual a "-b" más menos
y justo aquí es la razón del porqué puede haber dos soluciones, pues es que aquí tenemos un más/menos,
si "b" cuadrada menos "4c"
es un número positivo y mejor...
espera, espera, espera... mejor deja terminar
la fórmula, la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada
menos "4ac", todo esto entre "2a" y bueno,
déjame pensar un poco más en esto.
A ver, si "b" cuadrada menos "4ac" esto es
mayor que 0, ¿entonces qué pasa?
Bueno, si esto pasa adentro de la raíz, tenemos
un número positivo, por lo cual podemos sacarle
raíz cuadrada y después cuando lo sumemos
con "-b", vamos a obtener un valor para el
numerador, cuando tú lo restes a "-b", vamos
a obtener otro valor distinto en el numerador.
Así que cuando pasa esto, vamos a obtener
dos soluciones...
cuando "b" cuadrada menos "4ac" es mayor que
0, vamos a obtener dos soluciones.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa cuando "b"
cuadrada menos "4c" es igual a 0?
bueno, si la expresión dentro de la raíz es igual a 0 entonces tendremos que sacar la raíz cuadrada de 0,
la cual es 0, la raíz cuadrada de 0 es 0, por lo
tanto, nos quedaría "-b" más o menos 0
y no importa lo que le sumes o le restes 0,
siempre vas a obtener el mismo valor, así
que en esta situación la solución de la
ecuación va a ser "-b" entre "2a",
esta vez no vamos a tener más o menos pues no va a
ser relevante, por lo tanto, vamos a tener
una única solución, "-b" entre "2a", es decir, que si tenemos "b" cuadrada menos "4c" igual a 0,
entonces vamos a tener solo una solución.
Y bueno, ¿después qué va a pasar si "b"
cuadrada menos "4ac" es menor que 0?
bueno pues si "b" cuadrada menos "4c" es menor que
0, entonces es un número negativo,
el cual vamos a tener adentro de la raíz cuadrada
y entonces tenemos que tomar la raíz cuadrada
de un número negativo.
Y nosotros sabemos porque nosotros trabajamos
con los números reales que no podemos tomar
esta raíz cuadrada, pues no es un número real.
Así que en esta situación, no existen soluciones
o mejor dicho no existen soluciones reales
y bueno, cuando digo reales me refiero literalmente
a números reales, no a soluciones reales,
aquí lo voy a poner, no hay solución real...
no hay soluciones reales...
Así que una vez dicho esto, pensemos en el
contexto de esta ecuación que tenemos aquí,
que por cierto, en el dado caso que tú seas
muy curioso y te preguntas si esta expresión
"b" cuadrada menos "4ac" tiene un nombre especial,
pues si lo tiene, se llama discriminante,
el discriminante...
discriminante... el cual es esta parte de
la fórmula cuadrática, el que determina
el número de soluciones que vamos a tener.
Así que si queremos determinar el número
de soluciones que vamos a tener en esta ecuación
aquí, entonces no necesariamente tenemos
que resolver toda la fórmula cuadrática,
aunque tal vez no sea mucho trabajo pero podemos
determinar el número de soluciones evaluando
la expresión "b" cuadrada menos "4ac" y bueno
ahora si, llegó la hora de pensar en este
caso particular, vamos a buscar quien es "b",
quien es "a" y quien es "c", éste de aquí,
éste es "b", el que está al lado de la "x",
este otro que está al lado de la "x" cuadrada
es "a" mientras que éste, mi término libre es "c".
Y ahora si nosotros sustituimos buscando "b"
cuadrada menos "4ac" entonces me va a quedar,
14 elevado al cuadrado, -4 por "a" pero "a"
vale 1 por "c", pero "c" vale 49,
entonces por 49,  ¿y cuánto es esto?
Pues vamos a hacerlo,
¿cuánto es 14 por 14?
Lo voy a hacer por aquí, 14 por 14 y me queda
4 por 4 = 16 y llevamos 1, 4 por 1 = 4 y una 5
y después ponemos un 0 aquí y 14 por 1
es 14, ahora si sumamos me queda, 691... 196,
14 por 14 es 196.
Y bueno, por otra parte tengo 4 por 49, así
que vamos a hacerlo también por aquí,
4 por 49, 9 por 4 es 36 y llevamos 3, 4 por
4 = 16 y 3 = 19, 196 también
y cuando yo me tomo 196 menos 196, esto me da 0,
entonces estamos en el caso en el que el
discriminante es igual a 0.
O dicho de otra manera, estamos en este caso
de aquí, en el caso en el que "b" cuadrada
menos "4ac" es igual a 0 y por lo tanto estoy
diciendo que solamente tengo una solución
e inclusive si quieres podemos encontrar la
única solución, esta parte de aquí va a
ser la raíz cuadrada de 0 y por lo tanto
esto desaparece, así que las soluciones de
esta ecuación van a ser "-b" entre "2a" y
"-b" podemos sustituirlo es -14 entre "2a",
es decir, 2 por 1 lo cual es 2.
Y esto es igual a -7, esta es la única solución
de esta ecuación.
Pero si solo quisieras saber cuantas soluciones
tiene, solo tendrías que ver que el discriminante
0 y por lo tanto, solo vas a tener una solución.
Y bueno, también hay otras maneras podrías
factorizar lo cual también es sencillo,
pues esto que está aquí, es lo mismo que "x"
más 7 por "x" más 7
y con esto obtendrías el mismo resultado.